[Music]
here in this video we will reveal the
marvel gods that might appear nay that
will appear in doctor strange the
multiverse of madness
and which one of them might be the evil
of the storyline well the trailer of
doctor strange revealed a lot of things
that was shocking but in a good way it
showed him and three other variants of
himself wonder as a nexus being and
another variant of her as well we also
heard professor x saw many other
characters and at the end of it none of
them seemed to be central enough
as to be the main villain
but there were certain entities seen
both in the trailer and the poster that
was recently released
and they actually seem to fit the shoe
so subscribe if you haven't already and
now let's get to it
firstly shumar garad
one of the marvel universe's dark gods
that will appear in the upcoming movie
is shumar garath as seen in a trailer
probably in the beginning of the movie
as a limited avatar of himself in the
mcu shumo garath was a very powerful
omnipotent ancient demon that wielded
tremendous supernatural powers he is
thought to be one of chaos's primal
forces he was regarded as the most
powerful of the old ones he is
practically unstoppable in his native
dimension he has the ability to speak
with and control others both within his
immediate neighborhood and over spatial
barriers which is one of his numerous
mystical abilities
which he might be doing to wander
through the dark hole and influencing
her to become a puppet for his
objectives
in his home dimension he is extremely
massive almost bigger than stars which
appears to be tied to his power he has
always appeared much smaller on earth
despite the fact that it had been
revealed
uh that the tiniest fraction of
chumagarat's essence appears on earth
whenever he is invoked hence he has only
been seen at full force within his home
realm
in the trailer the tentacle creature
battling dr strange in the streets of
new york could be a fraction of what he
really is as i just stated just now
during the infinity saga in the comics
strange was forced by ebony more to
summon it
when thanos was invading manhattan and
was stopped by a combined force of the
avengers and the fight scenes in the
comics between shuma garath and the
avengers kinda looked eerily similar to
how dr strange was battling the tentacle
bees in new york okay but even though he
might make an appearance in the movie he
might not be the main villain
secondly sidorak the second dark god of
the marvel universe that might make an
appearance is sitarak this creature is
an immensely powerful entity described
as being both a god and a demon sidorak
was at one time worshiped on earth until
he was banished to the crimson cosmos
due to unrevealed circumstances he
exists as a deity with enormous magical
power his spouse are such that he can
lend the use of such powers past
dimensions via avatars and spells that
invoke his name including the crimson
bands of sidorak the same powers that
strange used to fight thamuz during
infinity war to try to remove the
gauntlet from the mad titan's hand
the reason as to why this deity might
appear in the multiverse of madness it's
as seen in the trailer when america
travis a girl that has the rare ability
to smash open star-shaped bottles to
enable her to traverse to multiverse
when she was seen to be strangled by a
strange demonic creature that was trying
to force her to create a star portal so
it might be able to escape to other
universes cetera
although powerful and devious might
still not be the main villain although
he could be one of many secondary evil
forces that will appear in the events of
the movie this could later on be
developed into another story arc for the
future dr strange movies
thirdly c'thon and yes we come to the
third entity in this list and this is
none other than k'thon the cthulhu of
the marvel universe
seen as one of the reflections in the
broken glass pieces of the poster of
doctor strange ii the multiverse of
madness this demonic slash god like
being might just be the big baddie of
the entire movie a hidden evil force
that in canon actually was the one who
created the dark hole you know the book
that won the maximoff was using to learn
how to cast spells
it was also known as the book of the dam
it was obtained by agatha harkness
during the events of one division who
brought it with her to west view in
order to amplify her powers
so she could manipulate wander's reality
without being noticed the book was later
taken by maximov who began studying it
and was also seen being used by doctor
strange in the trailer
so sometime after the events of one
division while studying the book maximov
heard the voices of her children crying
out for their mother and proceeded to
slam the book shut an alarm
this was very similar to how zoo wen wu
was lured into freeing the dweller in
darkness during the events of shangti
and the legend of the ten rings both of
them heard voices of their loved ones
and just like zoo and wu wander might
just be motivated to do everything in
her power to get back to her children as
she has lost everything in the present
mcu universe
now this brings us back to k'thon this
demonic godlike entity is the creator of
the darkhold book and might be employing
the similar tactic in order to be
summoned or to be free to enter the vast
multiverse from where he is trapped
cathorn can't take any appearance as he
pleases but is usually depicted as a
dark humanoid in a cloak he can also
manifest as a giant lovecraftian demon
or possess the bodies of any model
who gains sufficient link to the dark
hole or its corruptive magics such as
chaos magic some of his more notable
hosts in the past in the comics have
included the likes of quick silver and
the scarlet witch the scarlet witch
meaning won the maxim
this is the main reason as to why i
believe he will be the evil entity that
is slowly rolling the dice and playing
all of our heroes as pawns in a
chessboard the dark dreams are strange
the voice is calling out to wander hell
even as to why professor x said should
we tell him the truth
now what if the dweller in darkness
sidorak and maybe even shumagarath were
all minions of the next big baddie of
phase 5 of the mcu
or even not but
what if they were all at least to some
part an opening act into the marvel's
descent from infinity saga into a darker
cosmic horror villain
that will tear through all the
multiverses
this would be a good thing to the
universe the mcu
as mortal villains wouldn't seem to be
much of a threat as compared to thanos
and as we all know as time progresses
the villains must also be more powerful
at least in the movies that is
so what if these dark gods were an mcu
version of the fear lords a race of
cosmic entities that are as powerful as
gods and are extra dimensional some of
these include the dweller in darkness
although not the same as the one seen in
shanghai but having the same essence
they also include the nightmare despair
and others
what if what we are seeing now with dr
strange and chang ji is a prelude into
the future mcu movies where the universe
is threatened by these cosmic beings
so i hope you have enjoyed watching this
video
and with that we come to the end of it
so do hit that like button for support
and subscribe as well to be a part of
the mind cue family but most of all
smash that bell icon for regular updates
on new videos right here on this channel
till the next one take care fam